qu'est-ce que j'ai raté oh attends attends at-il
proposé de savoir si tu allais bien ce que
j'ai proposé en premier alors vas combattre un boom
ou quelque chose ouais vous agissez tous les deux
comme des imbéciles attendez moi aussi
oh vous êtes si fort wookie Bankside je
travaille beaucoup je  j'adore tu les connais mais comment
vas-tu protéger Maria si tu
ne peux même pas finir un bateau
oh ouais eh bien tu ne seras jamais un aussi
grand héros que ton père nous avons brûlé un doigt
sur mon visage tu ne me pointes pas du doigt sous
les coins voient ne sont pas stupides si puérils
viens à moi frère Manolo hein qu'est-ce que tu veux
un banjo